hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for it's yanni
pomnishi vs alireza furuji it is round
four of defeated candidates tournament
and it is uh quite a spectacular game uh
both of them have had a very very
exciting first three rounds of the
candidate salires are getting three
draws even though it could have gone uh
either way uh first two games were
pretty much him uh the defending tough
possessions but uh in in game three he
was really putting pressure on hikaru
but he car just found perfect moves and
he was able to uh to get a draw
whereas jan uh started the turn uh
tournament with a brilliant victory
against the dean liran in round one if
you guys haven't seen it do check it out
um i will put a link to it in the
description below also a wonderful game
but let's not spoil too much of what
happened in this game uh because uh well
every move is uh
uh well just to be
marveled at so let's dive straight into
it ian has the white pieces and he opens
with e4 alireza replies with c5 he goes
for the sicilian defense as you might
have er
imagined knight f3 d6 and the d4 playing
the open sicilian captures captures
knight to f6 knight to c3 and a6 going
for the neither variation of the
sicilian defense uh and nipple goes pawn
to f3 this is not a very common uh
common move so uh it definitely makes
sense to prepare it for for the
candidates tournament as it is very
solid and it could contain a lot of
poison so here we have e5 uh chasing
away the knife from an active d4 square
knight b3 and the bishop to e6 so this
is all uh basically the absolute main
line both of them have to know this they
are in the candidates tournament the
bishop to e3 bishop to e7 and we have
queen to d2 already uh saying that it's
going to be a wild game as alireza is
most likely castling kingside and yan a
very likely castling queenside that's
exactly what happens here we have
castles castles and now uh it is a race
who will attack faster will uh jan
attack faster on the king side or will
alireza be able to start pushing those
pawns on the queen side so knight beat
to d7 aeon starts pushing we have pawn
to g4 pawn to b5 and pawn to g5 we have
uh pawn to b4
uh and here uh knight back to e2 if you
go for trades here upon captures and g
on f6 it's not all that impressive uh
for example b captures on c3 queen
captures and down knight captures on f6
white can play knight to the a5 and
that's a
perfectly fine position for both white
and black and you can't capture an a2
that's basically your biggest issue
because if you capture uh we're just
going to play knight to c6 attack the
queen and the bishop capture on e7 with
check
and then play queen a3 to connect with
the bishop and the d6 pawn we can even
play this out if you guys are interested
check queen captures queen a3 now the
bishop has to go back and now we pick up
the central d6 pawn and after all is
said and done for example like this we
will have a past c pawn and this will be
very good for white so of course after
knight a5 you can't really do that you
can play something like rook to c8 but
still it's not a problem knight to c6
same thing will happen uh we're gonna
move the queen and now knight captures
an e7 uh queen captures and now we're
going to move the queen and you know
it's a it's a fine position for both
white and black
but black has a very very very active
game if he can execute d5 at some point
should be should be very nice for him uh
but okay uh knight to the e2 is the main
line and that's why uh of course ian
plays it um just in case you were
wondering knight back to e8 and now pawn
to f4 now young continues pushing on the
king side and alireza continues pushing
on the queen side pawn to a5 we have
pawn to f5 and now usually a4 is played
here this is the main idea and it is by
far the strongest move recommended by
the engine
but alireza prepared something else uh
he he wants to create winning chances in
every game and he goes for bishop to c4
and it's an incredibly rare move it's
been played only in a handful of games
and none of them in top level chess so
jan has to be very careful what he does
here and interestingly alireza pretty
much played all of the moves up until
this point instantly but also ian played
all of the moves up until this point
instantly and he replies pretty much
instantly here with king to b1
now the strongest refutation here is
knight to g3 and this is considered best
uh but that's only as far as we know who
knows what kind of engines they are
using for the candidates maybe on has
some sort of a super computer at his
disposal uh you know
we unfortunately we never um get insight
into into those things but uh you know
we can only imagine that uh so here
basically bishop captures real capture
so you're gonna play pawn to a4 chase
away the knight and knight day one and
this is now perfectly fine for white for
example if king at h8 you can start uh
further pushing with h4 a3 you can play
b3 some like rook to c8 and it's a very
very tough game to play white is always
better however only if you know uh
everything uh but after bishop to see
fournette plays a king to b1 and this is
now a much much different situation than
just pushing your pawns when the king is
on c1 because now if a4 the knight can
also retreat the c1 so okay this is what
all it is a place a4 knight to c1 and
now pawn to d5 striking in the center
and we always say if black manages to
execute the d5 without ruining his
position in the sicilian uh he should be
more than okay
and uh there are a couple of uh games i
mean i think maybe two games that reach
this position where he captures on d5
was played but here never plays f6 and
it is now as of move 18 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
alireza uh replies to this he captures
the pawn g captures on f6 and you don't
have to do it but
it's upon sacrifice so uh you know if
you don't accept it you're just gonna be
worse so g captures on f6 and now uh jan
recaptures with the g captures on f6
again he doesn't have to do this he
could uh try to claim some free squares
uh before recapturing but of course the
black will not capture black will just
continue development and at some point
we're going to have to recapture on f6
for example knight captures on f6 bishop
to h6 we're gonna go after the rook uh
and now uh when you play king to h8 you
have to be ready for queen to g5 and if
queen g5 rook to g8 now queen captures
an e5 it's um
incredibly complicated but also very
much playable uh however we have the
instant uh g captures on f6 we have
knight d captures on f6 grabbing the
pawn back and now knight the g3 and this
is uh the where the first real thing of
the game uh happened alireza started
thinking here and it took him some 30
minutes to come up with a move because
he has to uh you know where all the pro
pros and cons does he just go queen the
queen to c7 queen to c7 rook the c8 uh
creates some sort of an attack uh does
king the h8 um uh is king the h8
mandatory can he afford not to play it
or does he just you know go bishop
captures on f1 open up the c file right
away so there are many options here we
can show for example if king to h8 uh we
we're going to the force the bishop
captures the captures and everything
gets traded off so it's not a lot of fun
real captures knight f5 we go after the
bishop now we're going to play bishop d6
and you know it's a it's a it's a very
nice position white will have some
pressure but nothing serious we can
trade off the rooks characters capture
so it's nothing really so uh instead
alireza tries this bishop captures an f1
idea rook h captures on f1 and now pawn
to a3 uh the
if you go for something like d captures
uh
on e4 and you try to trade the trade off
the queens then queen the g2 is deadly
you do not want to play this so here
alireza plays the much much stronger
pawn to a3 now queen to g2 isn't all
that scary because if you play it now we
can capture here and now we're
threatening b captures on c1 with checks
so you don't even if you play one check
your knight five check you don't have
checkmate the knight here is covering
the square king h8 and you're perfectly
fine after king captures on b2 it's
gonna be it's gonna be black who's uh
gonna be
running the show here
uh with ideas like knight captures the
here rook to g8 and and so on uh rook to
b8 so instead after a3 and if it just
closes the position b3 we have king to
h8 now and e captures on d5 and now uh
what do you play here well there are a
couple of good options here alireza
could consider queen to c7 that's one of
the moves that
makes sense here
although you constantly have to worry
about this rook captures an f6 from nepo
if he plays this you're not going to be
able to capture back with the knight
because of this pawn push so that's very
annoying you're going to have to capture
with the bishop and then uh well it's
just knights to d3 and a very very nice
position for white if knight to d6 now
we're going to play bishop to c5 and
white is down the exchange but he has
this past pawn and constant pressure
with black then really having not not
all that much to do but it's a very very
active position and
you could definitely play it however
alireza went for knight to d6 right away
and this is now much much different uh
here he is offering the b4 pawn now it
looks scary capturing this pawn uh but
nipple is already up one pawn so
grabbing another one could mean uh no
rather sorry
the material is equal here and if he
grabs this pawn and if he can grab it
without ruining his pawn structure that
means he can also play c4 at some point
then he's going to have this massive
pawn chain here and it's not going to be
easy for alireza to play this but if
alersa gets the attack yeah then it
could be very very wrong for uh for eon
and now the problem is you don't uh
actually have a lot to think about here
if you don't capture right away let's
say you play knight d3
and you allow alireza one move knight
dita e4 comes with a tempo on the queen
uh that's pretty much it black is
winning here counters captures again you
can't capture the b4 pawn now knight to
c3 check is coming and it's going to be
all black from here let's say queen c1
knight to c3 check and now it's black
who will win this game
however after knight to d6 nipple spent
uh i don't know exactly how much but you
know maybe maybe a few minutes and he
grabbed the pawn right away queen
captures on b4 and now even though you
have some discoveries here none of them
are particularly useful
and
the this position is much much better
for white however you could still post
some problems here as black
if you play something like knights to d7
but
understanding why knight to d7 uh must
be played uh is is uh a very different
story from what uh actually happened in
the game because if you don't know uh a
a a certain trick nepo has at his
disposal you will not find knight to d7
but here just to give you an example for
example uh c4
we said that the pawn chain will at some
point come uh black might get some
counter play with f5 but still after c5
i mean uh you can see that uh even
though it's a very very uh ambitious
play from black white will be uh much
better here for example rook b8 attacks
the queen queen back to e1 we can even
play knight to b5 looks uh like
something is happening but still knight
captures on f5 uh we can play bishop
captures and c5 bishop captures knight
captures and now queen to g3 we threaten
checkmate black knight to defend this
we're going to capture an e5 with check
and now again white will be uh
either either winning on the spot or
maybe if black has some sort of a
miracle move maybe you survived this but
very likely white is just winning this
uh so even with the absolute best
defense uh it's still possible for white
to just forcefully win this however
after alvireza's move rook the c8 which
seems like a perfectly plausible move uh
it's it's really not because if you find
that the one move that nepal played uh
then you are truly the greatest chess
player ever uh maybe except for magnus
but okay maybe uh you know up there
uh and it took nipple exactly four
minutes to spot it so you have four
minutes i tried to find the best move
for white uh you know i'm not gonna give
you four minutes i'm gonna give you a
couple of seconds but you guys can pause
the video and have four minutes all to
yourselves
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the move
but it is uh white's next move that is
essential not the first one in order for
you to really real uh you know
understand the move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
bishop to b6 this is what young played
after some four minutes and now uh there
it uh there is no good move for alireza
even you did polgar who was commentating
on the game live said that this move is
far from obvious because leaving such a
wonderful diagonal you know for this
diagonal even with this tempo on the
queen if it's not winning by force it's
it's probably not a good move however
jan spots that it is winning by force
and the problem is next how do you block
this you can't block with a piece so you
are you're not going to play rook to c7
so if you play queen to e8 that loses
immediately you pretty much see that
rook captures an f6 we have to capture
back and we pick up the knight so two
knights for a rook of course we are
winning this so the real question is
what did dion see after queen to d7 well
uh jan saw this queen back to e1 and
that's a move you definitely uh
uh
can't spot easily bishop to b6 you know
just uh freeing up this path to the e5
pawn this is what nepal played and now
the reality is now nepo is already up by
one pawn and now he's threatening to
pick up the the other one and there's no
good way to stop this if you play if you
play something like pawn to e4 then you
allow this uh diagonal to be grabbed by
white and there is no defending this how
are you stopping uh all of the captures
on f6 if you play something like knight
to the e8 we can simply play knight
captures on e4 now we're just completely
piling up on that night and there's no
there's no saving this this is
completely winning so another thing you
might do after queen to e1 is knights to
g4 you might try to defend the pawn this
way but then we play h3 we kick away the
knight okay knight h2 attacks the rook
rook f2 now there is nothing if bishop
h4 looks scary but again we gladly pick
up the knight and now it's just a free
piece so
although it looks like there's something
there really isn't uh so here alireza
went for the only move that he could um
because it's such a such a terrible
position to play he played rook to b8
and now uh the position isn't his only
problem uh his real problem well the
position is a real problem but he
doesn't have time to realize that as he
is down to three minutes on the clock
and it's only moved 26 so you need to
make 14 more moves to reach time control
whereas nipple has over an hour on the
clock
and now okay the the bishop is attacked
and the idea is uh he wants the plane
knight to c4 the knight will not be uh
in any trouble because the the b pawn is
pinned and the knight from c4 will be
guarding the uh the e5 pawn so that's
kind of the basic idea and uh nipple can
just retreat the bishop wherever he
plays bishop to a5 okay knight to c4 by
alireza he played it pretty much
instantly as he's very low on time and
now nipple again has to figure out how
to play this pretty much any move is
winning for nipple and when i say pretty
much every move i really mean that so
just to give an example rook captures on
f6 is winning uh point is that if you
capture then we just play queen to f1
now we're attacking the bishop and the
knight so that's winning uh you don't
have to capture the rook you could of
course
uh instead of bishop captures an f6 you
could capture the bishop here but we're
just going to play queen captures on e5
and now good luck surviving this we're
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and of course if you capture
we're just going to capture back king
here rook to g1 knight will come with
all sorts of nasty discoveries uh there
is no surviving this and uh uh okay you
don't even have to play rook chapters on
f6 you could even just bring the bishop
to this diagonal
still completely winning how are you how
are you playing this uh let's say a
knight to g8 we're going to play bishop
captures on e5 even at the price of that
bishop knight captures queen captures
and now for example after f6 queen f5 we
are up too much material of course this
is completely winning for white uh but
nepo chooses the coolest way as he
usually does and he plays pawn to d6
just advances that pawn attacks the
bishop here so alireza plays bishop to
d8 offers a trade of bishops now alireza
is down to one minute on the clock nepo
is still over an hour on the clock and
bishop back to c3 now the bishop claims
this diagonal and you will not
[Music]
be able to survive this it's a winning
position for nepal plus less than a
minute on the clock for alireza uh queen
to e6 yes you are now successfully
guarding your pawn but it doesn't matter
just knight to d3 we again pile up on
the pawn uh also possible is king a1 i'm
just going to show it to just show you
how how awesome the position is um uh
so
what
what can you do here if you play knight
to b2 because now by moving the king we
are threatening b captures on c4 that
was impossible with the king and b1
let's say knight goes here we can
capture captures captures and captures
and again there's not much you can do
here white has four past pawns and even
though it does seem like black could
create some attacking chances there
really aren't any so but okay nipple
chooses the the the simpler one he goes
for knight to d3 again just piles up on
the e5 pawn knight to d5 now putting
pressure on the bishop here and now we
have knight to f4 again uh nipple i i
played this uh incredibly quickly
because he also wants all it is that uh
uh i have to play quickly he doesn't
want to allow already to think on
nipples time uh but again if you guys
are interested uh there are a couple of
ways to blunder this game for jana
actually for example if knight f5 uh
there's the scary knight captain c3
check which is what alireza found the
bishop captures and the queen captures
in bishop a5 uh is super scary so it
almost traps the queen
but not really you have to play this b4
move uh and then you you will squander
your your winning chances now knight
captures on d6 will come and uh you will
no longer be winning this game with
white so it is possible to ruin it
however young plays knight to f4 and now
we have knight captures on f4 rook
captures and pawn to f6 so all it is a
saves the e5 pawn but now queen to e2
now preparing queen to h5 also the punk
can not capture the rook because the
queen would hang also um well there's
still a lot of pressure on this knight
so the the queen can't really move so
knight to b2 now alireza is down to 30
seconds and now we have uh rook uh a
rook d to f1
rook to e8 so
you can start maybe moving the f pawn uh
and now of course you are threatening
pawn captures on f4 as the rook is
guarding the queen but now rook to h4
and now there really isn't any anything
for all it is i know i keep repeating
this every move but it's just such a
beautiful position where so many moves
are winning for nipple it's hard to
choose a great one here although played
f5 almost uh down on time completely
opening up an attack against the rook
and here whenever saw this he was very
happy because he knew that he was going
to sacrifice this rook on h7 of course
you cannot resist such a such a thing
even though you can play pretty much
anything you can like play a rook to h5
just move the rook you can play knight
captures on f5 air everything is winning
here you could capture on b2 probably uh
but he goes for it rook captures on h7
and now you are getting checkmated and
that's it king captures queen to h5 with
check king to g8 if you block with queen
h6 then we just pick up the rook here so
that's not helping so king to g8 and
here knight captures on f5 opening up
the g file for the rook uh bishop to f6
by alireza but now rook the g1 and he
was in this position on move 39 one move
before reaching time control that
alireza firoja resigned in the game and
jan gets another spectacular victory in
round four of defeated candidates
tournament so now he defeated the ding
in in round one and he takes down
alireza in round four uh which is simply
incredible uh he got surprised a little
bit uh
out of the opening but uh he just
blitzed out all of the moves uh against
alireza's preparation and then it's you
know that yeah over the course of like
four moves
had to spend all of his time on the
clock and the
there was nothing uh
he can do there so here you resign
because uh you can't block this check
whatever you block with bishop g7 or
bishop g5 we just capture it and if you
play king f8
uh then it's a forced mate in four just
queen h6 check king to f7 and now rook
to g7 check that's it if you capture
queen captures and g7 is checkmate and
if you move then queen h8 check queen
has to block and now of course queen
captures and g8 will be checkmate so
truly a spectacular game 39 moves but uh
again i feel it feel definitely feels
like a miniature and it's uh it's
incredible how how i mean how exciting
chestnut nipple is playing in the
candidates tournament but it seems to be
uh a recipe that that is working as he
also won the previous candidates
tournament so now you know leading the
tournament like this uh is definitely
uh you know the other players will have
to step it up a notch to catch up to him
but we'll see if he will be able to
create so many chances in in the other
games that are to come
or will his uh you know creative play uh
strike back against him we'll see we you
never know when nipple is playing he's
like the he's like the modern uh vasily
van chuk uh you know uh incredibly
talented incr you know absolute genius
uh except when you know something just
happens on the board
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh really really a wonderful
one we're not gonna spoil what happened
in the other games as as i'm going to
cover that as well and then we're gonna
discuss the standings a little bit but
yeah uh just countering uh
alireza's preparation with uh you know
either preparation or very very uh
uh qui quick uh over the board uh
calculation but whatever it was it was
it was incredible uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank algoria mourinho feliz uh
dani uh jeffrey tanato matan uh meru
francis air and casey vance for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day